in decision decision-making under
uncertainty in medical research thanks
you and thanks for the organizers is it
an opportunity for me to tell you about
some of the things that are happening
and decision making and clinical
research the outline is I'm going to
tell you about randomized trials you you
probably don't know much about them most
people don't even patients in them don't
I'll tell you about sequential decision
decision analysis and multi-armed bandit
problems I know that you many of you
know more than I do about them and
there's some sessions in the workshop
dealing with them but I'll give you my
perspective and it'll be pretty
elementary in developing them and taking
you back a few years my efforts to
interject an inject a decision analysis
into clinical research it's been a
frustrating experience for the past 40
years trying to get people to do what I
think are reasonable things in clinical
trials there have been some successes
naturally naturally but I'll focus on
two successes but the this is a work in
progress it's been at least 40 years
going on and it's there there's some
progress I'll show you the progress but
we continue to try to do better things
and biology is making us do better
things and that's where you come in and
that's the reason I'm here is to tell
you about this and to get you to have to
bring your your brains and your brawn
into the
into the problem along those lines
I'm organizing helping to organize a
meeting at the New York Academy of
Sciences on with this title the need to
accelerate therapeutic development must
randomized control trials give way so we
had a meeting we were scheduled to have
a meeting this morning and this is a
note that I sent to the other members of
the organizing committee I said I can't
make the call but by coincidence I'll be
giving a presentation at the workshop
this workshop my goal is to show
computer scientists how optimization and
decision making under under certainty
applies to connect clinical trials and
how in if in fact our CTS do give way
their expertise will help identity or
expertise will help identify better and
maybe even optimal replacements so what
are randomized clinical trials in 1940s
the state of clinical research was
anecdote case studies published case
studies for the previous almost 200
years some people have been trying had
been trying to get you know
evidence-based medicine that we still
hear about today but it was in the 1940s
that there was this transformative idea
to take an idea that was originally
Fisher's in re Fisher's in agriculture
and bring it into medicine
it was Radford Hill that brought it into
medicine it was randomization a pretty
simple notion where you eliminate bias
assignment bias of patients you know
sometimes a patient in the past was
given a particular therapy because the
doctor thought that was a pretty good
thing for that patient we didn't learn
much in the 1940
for originally in a trial of
tuberculosis and streptomycin Bradford
Hill randomized patients so if you came
in they flipped a coin and half the time
you got streptomycin and half the time
you got nothing and then they saw what
the results were and the results were
positive but that led to that innovation
being used through today in almost the
same sort of circumstance and almost the
same sort of sophistication 50/50
randomization sometimes everybody's
blinded you know that's it's dealing
with the patient there's a statistician
who knows what the assignment is but and
then at the end of the trial they open
up the envelope and publish the results
and increasingly trials have gotten
bigger we run randomised trials 10,000
20,000 patients and in cancer if you
know anything about what's happening in
the world of cancer biology where with
the genome with the various markers we
identify that this cancer caries is
driven by such-and-such
uncle gene one of many and one of many
in the same tumor and that's the the
cleverness of cancer and the reason we
haven't cured it and the biologist
builds an antidote it builds a antibody
against that marker what it means is
that we used to have breast cancer now
we have her2 positive estrogen receptor
negative akt positive pi3 kinase
positive finer and finer subsets of the
disease such we no longer have hundred
thousand patients with
or 200,000 in this country per year with
breast cancer we have these smaller and
smaller diseases and soon we'll be
treating every patient will have what's
called an orphan disease and we don't
know how to develop therapies in the
context of the randomized trial the
experimental unit is the trial where at
the end of the day you calculate a
p-value and you say this was
statistically significant or not now
when I started when I was a graduate
student started working on what I
thought was a clinical trial
a bandit problem I figured that this was
the way clinical research was conducted
when I got into you know after I
published my dissertation in 1972 on a
bernoulli to armed bandit problem' I
thought this was the a great thing for
clinical research I thought this was the
way clinical trials would be conducted
and I was aghast to find that not only
did they not do something like this they
never looked at the data so in a
clinical trial that's running you
designed the trial 5050 open up the
envelope and see whether it's positive
or negative you're addressing one
question and increasingly in the world
today we can't address one question and
make headway and indeed that one
question not only is this a five or ten
thousand patient trial but it takes
seven to ten years to run we can't do
that seven to ten years from now the
therapy that we think today is great
is going to be outmoded and so progress
is incredibly slow and we need
better procedures and procedures where
the experimental unit is the patient
rather than the trial
so in in 1985 I published what was at
the time a pretty comprehensive
assessment of what bandit problems were
including not only in statistics but in
engineering and computer science and
psychology and there is a an annotated
bibliography that discusses each of the
papers that we knew about at the time
things have moved on just to show that
I've done some things in bandits in 2002
and know the date is not important
somebody did a survey of physicians and
asked so why do we do clinical trials
what are we trying to accomplish and
they reported that many respondents view
the main purpose of benefiting
participants rather than creating
generalizable knowledge this view which
was more prevalent among specialists
such as pediatric oncologists that
enrolled greater proportions of patients
and trials conflicts with the
established principles of research
ethics the established principles of
research ethics are contained in
something called the Belmont report and
it says very specifically that we can't
when in a clinical trial you're in a
clinical trial you're a guinea pig we're
learning we're not trying to treat you
we're not the goal is not to treat the
patients in the trial and this to me and
maybe it was appropriate back then with
the randomized trial being the standard
you know the trial is the unit but it's
not appropriate today and you see that
there's some pushback among oncologists
as to you know is this the appropriate
thing to do so I've been trying on
various fronts to change this over the
course of time and more recently going
into the lay literature and this is a an
article in Fortune magazine where I talk
about what traditional trials are and
how they don't accommodate the amazing
changes in biology the trials have
sample sizes in thousands even though
increasingly the number of patients with
the disease
or in the hundreds or less even if we
could do it a large trial its results
will be irrelevant when they're finally
announced the patient should be the unit
of inference we shouldn't be doing
p-values we should be doing patient
values and we need to merge clinical
research and clinical practice
so I spent a lot of time trying to
persuade my colleagues and biostatistics
and in medicine to do other things too
you know look at the data and adapt to
what's happening with the width in the
trial and to modify the course of the
trial on the basis of what you're seeing
not only stopping early but adding drugs
dropping drugs looking at who's
benefiting from what trying to get
greater precision associated with that
subset etc things like that and it was a
stone wall and so I decided and I was
continually told Barry you're naive you
don't know what the facts are this is
not the way we do things and get out of
here so I decided I'd become a mole I
actually try to learn some of this stuff
this is a profile science did on me back
number of years ago and in one of the
statements is Barry would be the lead
statistician for the sealed seal GB is a
cooperative cancer group it's the cancer
and leukemia Group B breast cancer
studies he was not greeted warmly I
objected rather strenuously recall
recalls Craig Henderson breast
oncologist at UCSF who had heard that
Bayesian zhh were loosey-goosey in
adhering to the rules suffice to say
that I converted Craig Henderson and he
became somebody who even through today
is advocating doing adaptive things and
this is just to show you that I was
successful on that side
this says ranking and in specific field
highly cited researcher in a specific
field and the point is that this
specific field that's an emphasis under
infinity
is clinical medicine so I'm known in
clinical medicine what that means is it
used to be when I started out this CL GB
thing I'd suggest some radical things
and people would say you know well
that's not what we usually do eventually
and with my increasing acceptance and
this is a message for you if you want to
have an impact on a particular
substantive area to become a mall
eventually they said well dawn says it's
okay
so we can do this and I'll show you some
of the amazing ludicrous things that we
did so a two-armed bandit what is it or
Bennett eventually we do of course many
armed bandits you pull an arm you win or
lose
my focus was Bayesian as you gather and
do you have two arms two coins
probabilities of heads on the two coins
are not known they have a probability
distribution the Bayesian approach
anything you don't know has a
probability distribution so let's assume
we're starting out non informative prior
on both of the Bernoulli parameters back
here
I called them left arm right arm I
thought that was pretty cute so Row is
the right arm and lambda is the left arm
but here I'm changing it to a and B so
you have a probability distribution on a
a probability this distribution on B and
you get to pick one of them to start
with what do you pick well of course it
doesn't matter if you tell me a is
optimal I'll say well B is exchangeable
with a and therefore it's also they're
both optimal so you pick one you pick a
and you win $1 the probability
distribution changes
if you get X Eclipse if you get a
success then you are in this mode if you
get a failure you're in this mode and of
course you're comparing to the same the
arms are independent so you're comparing
to the same distribution from from
before Oh what to do well if you read
that thing about my dissertation you or
even if you hadn't you certainly would
say let's do if we got this let's do it
again let's do a again if we got this
let's switch and do B so you choose a
again say after you get a success and
you get a loss and now you're in this
situation so now what it's not so easy
they both have the same mean but they
have different variances or different
variabilities so there are different
reasons that one might want to do this
well what are you trying to do and so
let's set in a context for what you're
trying to do suppose you have that
you're going to run a clinical trial of
length n little n and at the end of the
trial you're going to use the one at one
and you can do adaptive things during
the course of the trial and the
objective is to maximize the expected
number of successes over the total
patient horizon which is a number bigger
than little n it's a number of patients
who have the disease we don't know
exactly what it will be in the future
but it doesn't matter much and as you
see what really matters is kind of an
order of magnitude of capital n and this
is something that was put forward
amazingly in the same issue of the
general American Statistical Association
1963 independently by two great
statisticians Ted Colton and Frank
Anscombe and they talked about you know
how to how to build a clinical trial
they didn't win in the battle because
they never had any influence on what was
happening in clinical research and the
goal is to treat patients effectively
whether back to the Belmont report
whether they're in the trial or not we
don't want to sacrifice the patients in
the trial we do want to learn from them
and recognizing you know people have
said to me well well yeah but you're
you're learning from the patients who
are in the trial and the patient's at
the end of the trial may get a different
treatment or a different probability of
getting different treatments because of
what you've learned and you're treating
the patients badly in the early part of
the trial and my response is it's always
good to delay getting sick so you're
subject to you know the uncertainties in
the early part and if you could wait a
couple of years to get a disease you
take benefit of anything that happens in
the in the meantime so the solution is
by dynamic programming as you all know
this is today if you use arm a you move
to do different things tomorrow either
state after you fail or succeed like we
saw in that earlier example if you use
our B you go down and the same kind of
circumstance now embed that into a
bigger picture the clinical trial in the
example is length seven and so you go
out to set these and this is a complete
description of the possible states
starting from today and going out till
you get seven total observations and
this is along the way the number on arm
a and the number on arm B and then the
various possibilities within these boxes
so here is everything that can happen at
the end of if you you know dumb you're
not doing anything clever you just
seeing the possible states after seven
total observations and one of these for
example so this is where you've got five
observations on a two on B and a number
of successes on a the number of
successes on B so 18 possibilities at
the end of the day and the numbers I put
in here I'm assuming capital n is a
hundred so at the end of the seven
there's another 93 patients that you
treat and you're going to use the one
according to the rule I set up the one
which had the better response at the end
of the seven for those remaining 93
seven is not a magic number here it's
just you know something I can show on
the page and these numbers I've written
down here are the numbers of successes
in the subsequent part of the problem in
the additional 93 patients so for
example if you've observed five out of
five successes on arm a it doesn't
matter what you observed arm on arm B
because you're going to use arm a for
the remainder and your probability of
success on the remainder is just
Laplace's rule it's just six out of
seven so it takes six seventh of 93 and
you get seventy nine point seven or
something like that round it off to 80
and so this is you know this is the end
of the random of the trial the
experimental part and we write down it
for every one of these possibilities in
the at the end and then we back up for
example this is after six this is one of
the many possibilities that you could
have it happens to be
for on a 2 on B and you had 3 out of 4
successes on a and 1 out of 2 successes
on B if you go to the right you go to
two dit one of two different
distributions to beta distributions
that's what happens if you get a success
you start with beta for two and you move
if this is unarmed a only and you move
to beta 5 2 or whoops or beta or 3
depending on whether you get a success
or failure and the neat thing about the
Bayesian approach is you can predict you
can say what is the probability of these
individual things and that's again just
Laplace's rule so there's a 4/6
two-thirds chance of success but one
sick one-third chance of failure and so
you can calculate the probabilities for
example here you're going to go to one
of these two clip places and this one
with probability 2/3 this one with
probability 1/3 take the average of
those two things and plug in that number
here and then fill it out keep going
back to the beginning and what I've laid
out here is not the numbers but which
arm you used which arm was the one that
gave the maximum for each of the states
and so what you see here along this line
in as you knew from the beginning since
they were symmetric it didn't matter
what you did so that's they're both
optimal it doesn't matter which way you
go but when they're shaded in you should
move down and when there's your no
shading you move to the right so back to
this case
that's a point here that's that point
and it says you should move down it says
as many of you knew this would be the
appropriate thing to do why is that
intuitively their two-digit errata
one is you want to make money or you
want to treat the patient in front of
you effectively and the other is you
want to get information that's going to
help you into the future and those two
things make the problem what it is I
mean making the problem incredibly
difficult to you know prove things about
for example and so this is what you do
and if you do write down the numbers
you'll find that the number that's
written in at the beginning is 63 63 is
the expected number of successes of the
hundred patients using the optimal
strategy that has this constraint that
you can be adaptive only in the first
seven if you compare other kinds of
designs for example this is the dumb
design the N equals zero you don't do
any experimentation you either use arm a
forever arm be forever any kind of
in-between and you're not looking at the
data then you get just the mean of the
two distributions so 50 is the is the
dumb answer it's also the answer for a
randomized trial by the way if you do
50/50 and are eggs answer was 63 if you
did the optimal adaptive design from the
beginning and did you know let the small
end be equal to big end and just to use
the optimal one at every step of the way
you get about 65 the maximum that you
can get is
66 and 2/3 that's just the expected
vessel called expected value of perfect
information if you have a uniform
distribution on this on the square and
you if I'm gonna tell you what the
answer is one second if you I'm going to
tell you what the answer is that is
which one is better what is your
expected value of what I tell you it's
the expected max of those two things
which is 2/3 yes sir
does this require you to know
immediately whether or not your arm was
a failure or a win which you have in
Malta unbanded said things but not
necessarily into medical trials I
imagine so no you know it this is your
starting at the beginning and I'm and
you've got this random variable random
distribution on on PA and PB and I'm
going to tell you whether which one is
bigger how much is that worth to you
well you're going to be able to proceed
with certainty that you've got the right
answer what is the expected value of my
of the information that I'm giving you
it's this 2/3 in the actual medical
trial like you have 100 patients and
patient 35 gets a and now before now you
have to don't you have to pull I'm 36
before you know the answer for 35 that's
my gosh yeah yeah so yeah that's a very
realistic and important problem and
you're right I should have said this
immediately that I'm assuming you get
immediate responses in the adaptive part
here and in in actually in some examples
in migraine for example in migraine the
so called registration endpoint you can
get a drug approved for migraine on the
basis of two hours pain free so you give
the drug and either the Negron migraine
goes away or a dozen so you're getting
the
Meishan right away if you're treating
horrible disease like pancreatic cancer
and the endpoint the outcome of interest
is mortality well even though they die
pretty quickly relative to the rest of
us it's still you know a matter of
months before you see the answer this
raises a very important thing that that
we're doing and and in your in your
modeling to take into consideration take
that pancreatic example the patient's
still alive after six months but the
patient has characteristics the tumor
has grown the tumor hasn't grown the
patient is in bed and can't get out the
patient is playing his second 18-hole
golf course for the day there's
information that you're getting along
the way and it isn't just waiting till
that final endpoint this is an issue
that I keep pushing everybody on and
it's it's it's a hard thing to sell
because I don't want to go into it it
but it's it's a very important issue for
the point of from the point of view of
adapting because we know we want
information to adapt to but it's also
important for understanding the disease
and so building these longitudinal
models of disease and it's one of the
the shames is when we publish papers and
cancer you know this traditional
randomized trial a versus B we say what
the survival is for a what the survival
is for B and we compare them we say what
the progression time was for a and
be and we compare them we say what the
response was for a this is a tumor
response a tumor decrease in size or
didn't was for a and for B we give other
characteristics of what's happening but
it's all marginal you can't put it
together it's only you need to get the
raw data to put it together but nobody
does that because they don't appreciate
you know this the information aspect
thanks for that great question so I'm
not sure I understood everything but you
said the word surrogate well they're
also you know time varying coverage all
kinds of things you could do I'll tell
you what I do
and some of the trial is going to I'm
going to be showing you is i conditioned
on the information that's going over
time so not only do I get the final end
point but I get the assessment of the
MRI in breast cancer you know where we
leave the tumor in the breast and we get
an assessment over time of how big it is
so I use that and I I have a model a
longitudinal model that has parameters
that I don't know that I update
including depending on treatment and
then I calculate the predictive
distribution for each patient in the
trial and the usual way that I do that
is multiple imputation so I have this
model and I impute for each patient what
the eventual outcome is and then I do it
again and again and again that gives me
the
you know the overall probability
distribution excellent point
so an RCT for seven gives you sixty two
point four
I mean you are getting you know three on
one and seven and four on the other one
or vice versa
an interesting thing here theorem if
you'd like to try to prove it is for an
RCT and odd is actually better than
getting one more patient this this means
to me
strict better so seven is better than
eight it's better to experiment with
seven to constrain yourself to a smaller
number in this randomized trial which of
course doesn't happen in the adaptive
setting so I'm not gonna say anything
I'm gonna not going to show anything
about this but if you compare the
Bayesian adaptive approach in the
scenario I just gave you versus an RCT
or versus something like to play the
winner rule of play the winner rule is
whatever you got as a success on the
last one you if it was a success on the
last one you use it if it's a failure
you switch and use the other one this
point of this is simply to say that even
though the Bayesian adaptive approach is
optimal over all that is on the average
with respect to the prior distribution
it's also better than these two and and
many others point wise so regardless of
what the truth is it finds out the truth
certainly in the large sample setting
but even in the moderate sample settings
so decision analysis of trials lists the
possible results calculate the
predictive probabilities of each of the
possible results this in itself in and
if you work with clinical trial lists is
an innovation people do things for the
strangest reasons and if you ask them so
ok so suppose you do the trial and you
get this what would you do next and they
say well I would do such-and-such I said
ok suppose you get these data instead
what would you do next well I would do
such-and-such the same such-and-such
that is you do the same thing no matter
what then why are you doing the trial so
write down the possible answers and
write down the implications of those
answers as evaluate the utility of those
results and the predictive probabilities
and then average that gives you the
average utility of the strategy or in
the decision analysis term the utility
of the strategy the utility is its
average with respect to the probability
distribution and compare utilities for
the various strategies for the various
designs and use the one with the highest
what gives you the optimal but you know
sometimes for logistical or other
reasons you might use something that
just was pretty good
choosing a sample size again the utility
is patients in the trial treat patients
effectively in the trial and after the
trial and again the same sort of setup
that I was doing before patient horizon
is end it's enough to know its magnitude
I say so this is an example decision
analysis example how big should a trial
be and now even this is randomized a
decision analysis of randomized equally
randomized trials and I just kind of set
the context here I said suppose you have
you're going to do one trial and then
use the one that's effective the
treatment is effective in that one trial
whether it's a two-armed trial or a
one-armed trial and let's suppose that
if there were a million patients that
you're trying to treat effectively you
know something like coronary artery
disease and the optimal sample size is a
thousand how big could it be with the
same setup the same probability
distributions but with a smaller sample
size if the sample size is if the
population size is only a hundred
thousand then it's you know a third of
what it was here you'll notice in
looking at these that these are just the
square root of these if you had two
trials that is you do one trial look at
the results do a second trial and you
know that that second trial can have a
sample size that you choose based on the
result of the first trial how big should
it be under the same scenario which gave
rise to this 1,000 and the answer is the
cube root
all the way along here so we actually
proved that and we of course conjectured
that if you had three trials that it
would be the fourth root but we couldn't
prove that or we couldn't prove in
general that result the point is and if
you show this to a frequentist
biostatistician that's that's drunk the
kool-aid this is irrelevant the way they
design trials is they pick a clinically
significant difference control type one
error have eighty percent power and
that's the answer the population size
doesn't matter so you do the same thing
in breast cancer or cardiovascular
disease as you would in relapsed Wilms
tumor which is a tiny tiny you know less
than 100 patients per year in the United
States
you'd have the senton do you do the same
thing what does that mean you can't do a
thousand patients in relapse Wells tumor
so if you go to the NCI or National
Cancer Institute with a you know one of
these corporate Boop's and you say I
want to do this trial and relapse well I
know because I've done this in in
relapse Wilms tumor and I want to you
know look at a small number of patients
and learn from that number of patients
you know like 20 patients and move on
you can't do that I said why can't I do
that because you don't have enough power
and it's this artificial thing that
somehow you know you and so you what
does that mean there are no learning
trials in real Absalom's tumor because
they won't fund it and there's it's a
niche disease and so pharmaceutical
companies aren't interested in doing a
clinical trial especially in view of the
attitude the things that are changing
but that's the current attitude
I want to get on to some other stuff so
I'm going to skip this just to mention
that back in 1933 even older than I am
Thompson suggested a neat strategy which
is not an optimal strategy in any sense
and he says it's not optimal it's not
the best possible but it it seems like
it would be pretty good what you do is
at each time it's a Bayesian approach
what you do at each time is you
calculate the probability that a is
better than B and then you assign the
next patient with that probability so
that's a you know an adaptive
randomization it's not optimal but it's
it's not bad it's what Google does by
the way in the search engine stuff and
it's what I've done in a number of
settings and I'm going to this is one
example and I'm going to skip that
see I do give you cautionary tales where
the result of this adaptive trial that
we did using something like the Thompson
approach nobody believed it the company
didn't believe it and so they ran
another trial you know a so-called real
trial and they ended up killing lots of
patients because they didn't believe it
and and they're coming around so and
just to say that there are things you
can do not only in the context of
treating patients effectively but
getting information you know this is an
example of a diabetes drug where you
there are seven doses so seven arms
actually more than that because there's
control arms and you want to adaptively
address the question what is the dose
response of this drug and this one was
very successful I spy two is a trial
that I designed in breast cancer
it's here's a cartoon explaining the
trial and the big deal here is that the
population is heterogeneous explicitly
so so we look at various biomarker
characteristics in the population and we
have this one in this particular case at
this time
we're adaptively randomizing five
experimental arms and standard therapy
we're up to eleven experimental arms now
arms come and go trial still going on so
we might at one time identify this
subset as responsive to - arm - we might
drop arm three because it's not doing
very well identify a different subset
that responds to arm five
we calculate type 1 error rates and all
of this stuff by the way
which is not so easy as in the two-armed
setting and as time goes along we fill
in other arms and the goal is always
looking forward it's we want to identify
a subset and a drug matching the two
that have at least an 85 percent success
rate in a phase 3 trial predictive
distribution the goal is to have a small
phase 3 and just to show that we're
making some progress this was 2 months
ago in the New England Journal of
Medicine a paper coming out of this
trial this is one of the therapies that
graduated in a particular signature and
not only one but two this is kind of
unique for the New England Journal of
Medicine to have two tandem results for
the same trial and not only that but an
editorial by two MDS and also a
perspective by two statisticians so for
articles and at one issue of a New
England Journal of Medicine dealing with
ice by two so it's you know it's we're
making some headway and we give Bayesian
distributions and we say for each of the
possible signatures these are subsets of
subtypes of the disease what is the
report card but also what is that your
major where where is the one you
graduated in and for nur at nib you the
graduation was in her to positive
hormone receptor negative breast cancer
the thing I want to say about this is
merely that of the 11 drug so far that
we've looked at fully five of them have
graduated breast cancers is a disease
that is highly sensitive to therapies a
number of therapies hormone therapies
chemo therapies targeted therapies and
so these five have graduated to Phase
three with different sample sizes why
because we're looking constantly and
we're saying are we there yet
do we know what the answer is and we're
adaptively randomizing the narrative
graduated but along the way the data
safety monitoring board said to me you
know Don this is a hard drug to give and
it's not doing very well in this subset
of disease maybe we should amend the
trial and drop that subset and I said
you don't have to look at the
randomization probabilities the
algorithm has already predicted that and
is giving that patients in that subset
no rat nib with probability zero but
meanwhile it's doing very well in this
other subset these are the goals and I
want to tell you finally about GBM agile
this is a trial I just came back from
Australia that's one of the countries
juris China is also in gb n G BM is
glioblastoma multiforme II it's the
brain tumor that killed Beau Biden Ted
Kennedy it's the most common brain tumor
it's also the worst brain tumor and
nothing works for it
so we're we're building a an
international trial and I want to show
you something about it
this is the way it works new patient
comes in
I say it's I spy two on steroids it's a
registration trial the I spy two was a
face so called Phase two trial
predicting for Phase three
this trial is actually including phase
three in it in a confirmatory subset so
a patient comes in gets randomized
according to you know the adaptive
randomization we update the patient data
we update the longitudinal model this
thing I talked about before we calculate
the probability that the arm is better
better than control and we make
decisions one decision is to stop for
futility another is to stop because we
reach the max of a hundred and fifty
patients in the stage one another is to
continue in stage one and the another
set of possibilities that you can
graduate if you graduate then you may
move into depending on what we decided
about that therapy in advance into a
stage two which is you get a fixed
randomization for the next 50 patients
and you you could stop a cruel and give
it back to the company and then we
continue and add new experimental arms
if we can afford that in terms of the
accrual rate of the trial we update the
probabilities according to subtype
determine the randomization
probabilities and keep going so it's
it's like ice by two potentially never
ending it may serve as the way to
process these simulations are required
and a consequence of inadequate
simulations in clinical trials is
similar to what this particular example
of inadequate simulations at SFO so the
last thing I want to do is this it's
like a four do I four minutes I'm down
to zero can I show a four minute video
or not
you've seen it before a ship rust so
what do you think is it worth the four
minutes there's a there's a danger
associated with it and that is the
danger is that you may change your
vocation and want to go into science
this really Stern foundation for
multiple disciplines and countries met
as part of an unprecedented
international collaboration take a
scientific crowdsourcing this is a an
Australian small group and a
transformative idea found ashes grew to
include a hundred dead is an advocacy
group for is brain cancer had to forego
and so they put this together and they
just listen to what I was saying over
time to develop put this together they
did a great job adaptive clinical trial
to tackle one of the world's deadliest
diseases the malignant brain cancer
glioblastoma multiforme II or GPM we're
here to do something does that's
different
something that is historic dr. Timothy
quasi the principal investigator of the
GPM agile says it is more than a
clinical trial it is a learning system
that offers unprecedented opportunities
to identify effective therapies for GBM
I'm always amazed when we get it worked
like this together this many real
leaders in its field to begin to listen
to each other and change their mindset
open up their minds to new ideas and
then that's what this is about actually
I think what we need on here is not
during the tumor or running the trial
that's what adaptive trials are a faster
drug development more efficient more
accurate and hopefully bringing better
therapies to traditional clinical trials
typically only test one therapy against
the standard of care they follow up
one-size-fits-all approach we don't know
who will or won't respond so we learn
next to nothing adaptive trials allow us
to separate patients on the basis of fly
learn what works and apply that learning
to the next patient they make it
possible to test multiple drugs and
combinations saving a lot of time and
money as new biomarkers are identified
more patients can qualify for inclusion
increasing the number even access to new
treatments everything is brought
together in a continuous learning system
setting a new course that can be
replicated for other rare diseases it is
going to take an international effort to
accrue enough patients to test enough
drugs to explore enough biomarkers to
really revolutionize this disease it's a
pilot it's a new paradigm
it would be a model for many other types
of cancers EPS works so it's a good
learning system for China to the the
innovation comes from a determination of
artists group to affect great change and
what they call the Coalition of the
Willing and it's the desire to serve the
needs of patients by having the
condition the egos go out you know and
what you end up with is pure
collaborative integrity people always
ask me the question you know when you do
these big things what makes you think
that people will want to participate boy
why would you not want to participate
when you can change the world
the end just a questions of mine